[Musique]
première étape à l'université de
versailles-saint-quentin l'adoption de
nouveaux statuts mi novembre suivie en
février par l'élection d'un nouveau
conseil d'administration plus resserrée
limitée à une vingtaine de membres il
aura en charge la désignation du ou de
la présidente
mais pour les étudiants le premier
changement à se faire sentir
interviendra dès janvier la loi
d'autonomie ajoute l'orientation et
l'insertion aux missions du service
public de l'enseignement supérieur un
bureau chargé de diffuser les offres de
stages et d'emplois sera par exemple
créer et les universitaires en
difficulté seront mieux encadrées le
taux d'échec en première année en france
est de 50% en fait l'échec souvent en
1re année n'est pas dû à d'échec à
l'examen mais en fait est due à la fuite
des étudiants qui au fil du temps
abandonne et c'est cela qu'il faut
absolument aussi privilégié en essayant
d'éviter qu'ils abandonnent
définitivement tout et qu'on puisse
éventuellement les réorienter sa cls
point qui va changer de façon importante
par rapport aux six à sept fois avant le
mois d'août 2008 les compétences des
universités seront élargis elles
pourront notamment avoir en charge la
gestion de leur patrimoine immobilier
puis d'ici à cinq ans le coeur de la
réforme devrait avoir eu lieu
chaque établissement géré à son propre
budget c'est sur ce point que les
syndicats étudiants semblent le plus
divisé certains craignent qu'en fonction
de leur environnement économique les
universités et plus ou moins de
ressources
on sait très bien qu'une lumière
spéciale est implanté sur un bassin
économique elle va plus facilement aller
chercher de l'argent ça pose un problème
parce que d'une sacrée des unités de
vitesse et deuxièmement ça pose un
problème puisque l'intérêt de délivrer
des diplômes c'est un intérêt à long
terme
aujourd'hui si les universités vont
chercher l'argent
un court terme les diplômes seront
également des diplômes à court terme
l'unef est excusé mais s'ils sont
toujours sur une posture de de négation
de tout donc ça me semble pas très
productif constructif c'est un marché
concurrentiel puisque on a on part de la
fuite des cerveaux et cetera donc pour
nous c'est important de que l'université
française dispose de nouveaux moyens
pour se mettre à niveau dans la
compétition internationale
à l'origine de la réforme la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur n'exclut pas de
nouvelles évolutions mais pas avant un
an d'ici un an
nous ferons une évaluation de la loi
nous verrons ce qu'il va ce qui ne va
pas ce qui va moins bien ce qui va très
bien donc dans rendez vous dans un an
pour l'amélioration de la loi éventuelle
mais d'ici là il faut l'appliquer
ça va demander effectivement pour des
universités les plus récentes et qui ont
été les moins bien dotés au départ est
bien d'être encore plus innovante que
par le passé voilà
jeudi 22 novembre 8h45 le tribunal de
commerce de versailles a prononcé la
mise en redressement judiciaire de la
société d'alain prost
l'avocat du champion du monde de formule
1 est venue déposer une déclaration de
cessation de paiement c'est à dire que
la société estime ne plus pouvoir
assurer le paiement de ses dettes
cette déclaration halal entraîne le gel
le gel des passifs antérieures c'est à
dire tout son passif qui était
exigible
est exigé pour certains a été bloquée
pendant la période de six mois pas
pendant toute cette période les salariés
seront normalement payer donc seront
normalement payés et les créanciers qui
vont continuer à travailler avec prost
devront être également devons être payés
normalement il n'ya que ceux qui ont des
créances antérieures à l'ouverture de la
procédure qui eux voient lampe passive
gelé al'annonce du redressement
judiciaire le tribunal de commerce a
désigné un juge commissaire chargé de
surveiller la procédure un représentant
des créanciers et un administrateur
judiciaire
ce dernier doit servir d'intermédiaire
pour trouver de nouveaux actionnaires à
prost
les sociétés intéressées ont jusqu'au 6
décembre pour se faire connaître dans
six mois soit les capitaux sont rentrés
et prost repas soit rien ne se passe et
le tribunal peut procéder à la
liquidation judiciaire ce qui
signifierait la fermeture de
l'entreprise
[Musique]